welcome to this video playing playing DD
from France I don't like to play against
this gambit line with before this one
always played Bishop d7 okay get a
normal advanced french now with a three
let's let's go for the the blocking
variation not the only line against a
three you can also play f6 or 97 but
this leads to two tents play very young
very close position but interesting oh
it's very quickly advancing on the King
side
hmm okay I probably should prevent g5
for the moment it's not not deadly or
anything but better prevent it from the
moment yeah that's the whole point of
the the night maneuvers getting the
bishop into play hmm he really wants to
play g5 is it is it so so dangerous
takes Knight takes rook takes h5 see
yeah maybe he's second on on on edge on
f7 or something it's hard to believe
maybe yeah it's not there's not much I
can do about it I can try to prepare
castle sounded okay this is what's the
point always play this one surprising
yeah I need to Casa long probably anyway
are there was an idea okay okay need to
go back okay let's get let's get the
King off after the Queen side
and now I can go here though I have some
some serious I can't counter play here
on the queenside I'm his pieces are I
really clocked up in a way night a
foreign probably this is threatening to
take on d2 and maybe I could have done
that anyway but it's difficult for him
to move even maybe nighty to f3 here hmm
okay maybe I should have taken should
have taken unknown on the two first
maybe maybe
I can never take here anyway opening up
this diagonal is some is insane okay now
I probably need to take
I'm exchanging those because now the B
porn is my target
okay hmm Jan getting it into a self pin
cannot be cannot be good really okay not
not sure how to continue
it's a waiting move I'm unsure what to
do here I probably a silly waiting move
to be honest okay Isis he feels somehow
obliged to do something
hmm isn't this helping me I've got a
target on c3 now not sure but it doesn't
look too bad now I want to be able to
move the Queen maybe I can move it here
g5 and enter enter the position yeah
this is a question
yeah i cannot i cannot i cannot allow
him to know i cannot do that Queen g5
was what originally intended I cannot I
cannot do that can enter on d6
I'm too slow what no I wanted to play
Roxy form Queen Queen to f8 what's the
problem I don't know 20 seconds is the
main problem
time warning now yeah that's a shame i'm
pretty sure that wide was completely
outplayed at some point is overlooking
knight c6 of course now it's very easy
to play if the opponent will lose on
time check
check come on I can resign us black
society I was just playing this too
slowly I don't know around here i think
i'm just-just an excellent shape I just
need to play it differently whatever you
do be sure takes the two year I need to
take here and then it's just it's just
over it's um i played this night a 42
quickly it's also good it's also good
but the other is just more convincing
yeah that's really the spot where i need
to need to strike now add this this is
also still good for black I mean the
comp is on minus one point something but
still need to play all that maybe this
wasn't a good idea but still I mean I'm
the one with the pressure on the
queenside but I didn't really find a
good a good plan IAM a six was stupid i
guess but them yeah but before it's just
just terribly terribly bad it just opens
up the queenside and gift gives me the
target on c3 here i'm clearly better
again but still not easy not easy Queen
to d8 mmm I tried something similar but
he went for that and that's a good move
that's a good move
I cannot I intended to go here but this
I was scared about that may be unjustly
so here this is in fact good for black
yeah maybe I should have go for that
done around here it's not not easy at
all it was a it was a clear mistake
there me to allow the Queen to go to 12
aid this was a clear mistake yeah this
move is just bad I saw it pretty quickly
afterwards but this is just bad I also
panicked a bit because of the time I can
I just need to stay put here the thing
is it's very difficult for him to do
anything I mean as I spoiled some of my
my advantage but it's difficult for him
to do anything I mean you cannot really
take here because of this move when this
how does he ever make any progress very
very difficult compounds to play King
moves and just stay put yeah I was
supposed to slow him thanks for watching